these are the times that try men's souls
the summer soldier and the sunshine
patriot will in this crisis shrink from
the service of his country but he that
stands it now deserves the love and
thanks of man and woman
Thomas Paine the American crisis
December 19th
1776
America has had many crises since the
winter of 1776 though none so bleak as
that first one we're in a crisis now
caused by a falling away from the
principles of 1776 the immediate way to
understand the American crisis is the
fact that the government is at the point
of becoming an unlimited government I
mean goodness it's about to bankrupt the
richest country in the history of man it
is a crisis unlike anyone that is
previously met because it is
self-inflicted and it is wholly
avoidable America has been in a
slow-motion emergency since
progressivism began to erode our
constitutional foundations we are the
last best hope of the world and we're
into my mind a very very unfortunate
period of turning our back on first
principles we have to fight for our
liberty and if we don't have a rebirth
in in learning and liberty we're gonna
lose it any political renewal in the
United States will start from B based on
the two great documents the Declaration
and the Constitution which means it
begins with the study of those in the
mind of the founding fathers what is the
responsibility of government and because
our College has never forgotten those
principles and never abandoned that task
we're going to help provide that spark
the founding fathers through the
Declaration of Independence held that
all men are created equal
they're endowed by their creator with
certain unalienable rights that among
those are life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness let's try to figure out
what those things meant yes in the USA
we were founded on universal principles
and the answer key if you will for those
principles is the Declaration of
Independence
dekes was the purpose of government is
to preserve those rights from any
intrusions of government on that
individual yes ma'am that's what the
role of government does it doesn't give
us a right we have our natural inherent
rights from God and the government is
there to protect those for us I think
the most important word and the
declaration is secure the governments
are instituted among men to secure their
rights but give us rights the rights
pre-exists government inspired by the
ideals of America's founding a small
group of Ministers started a college out
on what was then the frontier hills oh
it was founded in 1844 by a bunch of New
England preachers moving out on the edge
of civilization they started it with
next to nothing one of our founders went
riding his horse for two years around
Michigan and Indiana and Illinois and
Ohio and Wisconsin we still have the
list of the people who gave three and
five dollars a time it came back with
twenty five thousand dollars a princely
sum
from the beginning they were guided by
the principles of the Declaration that
all would be welcomed in the pursuit of
the life of the mind regardless of
gender and regardless of race we think
it may be the first institution in
history anywhere anytime any kind of
institution with a charter that says
we'll take our student body without
regard to race sex or national origin
that's what civil rights leaders of the
60s aim for if you said to dr. King 50
years hence what would you like the
society to be like I suspect he could
look at Hillsdale and say I'll take that
being lovers of freedom the founders of
Hillsdale College were deeply involved
in the slavery crisis and had a lot to
do with the founding of the party that
elected Abraham Lincoln president the
platform on which Abraham Lincoln was
elected president States was written in
the Maine by to Hillsdale College
professors so Lincoln said in the
Gettysburg Address four score and seven
years ago our fathers brought forth on
this continent a new nation conceived in
Liberty and dedicated to the proposition
that all men are created equal where
would he have taken his instruction from
ideas of Liberty
yes sir mr. Brooks well he would have
gotten the idea of Liberty in the United
States being conceived in Liberty from
the Declaration of Independence at the
time there were people arguing that your
rights came from things like your your
race or your status in society but
Lincoln's argument was that it came from
your status as a human being yes sir
during the revolution we claimed that
all men were created equal in the Civil
War we fought to prove that
walking the campus with dr. Arnn he
stops in front of the monument and he
says when the Civil War broke out every
male student left Hillsdale to enlist
the Battle of Gettysburg would have gone
differently if there hadn't been about
30 or 40 boys from Hillsdale College in
the worst place in the battlefield
and by the way we didn't make those boys
go we taught them to love freedom and
they rallied to its defense the next
major challenge to these principles the
principles of the founding emerged in
the late 19th century progressivism
Woodrow Wilson elected president in 1912
became the first president to criticize
the American Founding which he did root
and branch it was not a peripheral
criticism he said the founders may have
been right in their simple era but we
complex modern people with our complex
modern nation know that limited
governments a mistake there for the
separation of powers is a mistake
therefore the idea that government
exists solely to protect pre-existing
rights is not nearly ambitious enough
and he thought that his political
science was far in advance of the
founders and that we needed a kind of
refounding of the country's politics in
order to stay abreast of the times
Wilson's thoughts make sense at first
glance because he was saying how can a
document or having two documents from
the 1700s govern us in an age where now
we have airplanes we have cars and I I
think it makes sense in that regard but
when you think about the fact that human
nature has not changed what Wilson is
saying is essentially the exact opposite
that the things things need to adapt and
change over time in a sense that they
are not eternal progressives believe
that there are superior intellects
that superior intellects ought to help
it sometimes coerce their fellow human
beings into a better state of perfection
they're all about changing you and me
and they are not about unchanging truths
and natural rights they're about the
perfectibility of the human species very
dangerous to believe in that and they do
the Wilsonian tradition went from there
to today where it's enthroned as it were
in the halls of Congress in an hour the
progressives went from Woodrow Wilson to
the presidency of his former assistant
secretary of the Navy Franklin Roosevelt
to Franklin Roosevelt's young Protege
from Texas young congressman Lyndon
Johnson next to be present to the fourth
transformative progressive President
Barack Obama as government continued to
expand inevitably it intruded into
higher education successive
administration's issued evermore onerous
regulations forcing colleges to comply
if they took federal money which
Hillsdale never had then the government
tightened the noose in the Carter
Administration we heard from the
Department of Health Education and
Welfare they said we realize you don't
take any direct aid to the college from
the federal government but your students
are getting aid like the GI Bill because
of that we get to regulate you
comprehensively whatever we want
hundreds of pages of stuff you have to
comply we sued them and the suit went
all the way to the Supreme Court and we
lost so to be free from government
intrusion
we have refused all federal funding
direct or indirect a heavy hand of
liberalism would have been brought to
bear on education at Hillsdale both in
terms of the content of the student body
but eventually in terms of who's hired
for the faculty what is being taught in
the classroom
there really is a you would be making a
bargain with the devil
if you had conceded an inch to them on
this question and two hills dales credit
it did not concede an inch well the
college is an expensive thing to run and
most of our competitors are getting 30%
of what they call student revenues from
the government and so we make that up
and we make that up by hundreds of
thousands of people have been generous
with our college
my mother died left me a fortune what
better way than to help people go to
kill still unlike the distant federal
government those stills donors know the
students they support I'm working my way
through college and I'm just really
really grateful and my parents everyday
are so grateful as well you know I
appreciate the letters I get good
highlight of my week oh so good each one
of these bubbles is full of the gas
methane
with its hard-won independence Hillsdale
is free to pursue truth and defend
Liberty what do we want the college to
be like in ten years the center of
gravity will have shifted what is now an
exciting on-campus phenomenon will be
recognized nationwide because of its
unique mission Hillsdale has drawn major
international leaders to its campus and
events the best of these speeches are
put into a publication called in Primus
which reaches millions of people
nationwide I heard of it through a
friend of mine who's I think the first
conservative ever met and so he gave me
a copy of in Primus my journey to a new
political understanding took a great
deal of time and certain amount of
salubrious pain I was impressed first of
all by the exactitude of the writing and
in Primus there was academic in the best
sense as it attempted to take one back
to first principles in two states and
cogently could you could you tell me a
bit about your Graduate School of
statesmanship this is the first graduate
school at Hillsdale its MAS and PhDs and
politics will spread hills dales
learning to universities and other
institutions across the nation you'll be
focusing mostly on the first principles
of American constitutionalism and the
fate of those principles over time it
gives a degree in the great books that
are necessary to understand the American
Revolution and politics and man in
general keeps saying all we need is more
regulation seems like Kirby Center in
Washington DC brings Hillsdale students
to the capital for classes and
internships
it also offers educational programs for
Washington policymakers it's in the
belly of the beast
speaking truth to power it's a kind of
reverse missionary work in which from
the provinces you send missionaries to
the center rather than the other way
around
and that's because they're most needed
in the center hello and welcome to
Constitution 201 Hills deals online
course on the constitutional style
offers free online classes for citizens
nationwide who want to learn what
evidence do you have that it's possible
to recover the older understanding of
the Constitution historical parallel
would be Lincoln who did just this he
showed it was their first constitution
course with two hundred thousand people
signed up to listen to the great
scholars of Hillsdale really I think
surprised me and surprised everyone else
that there was that kind of hunger for
that kind of serious but very winsome
learning please join us next week
in every major crisis since the middle
of the nineteenth century including the
Civil War our College has played an
important part and always the same part
we are faithful to the things we were
founded to do and they are just like the
things that the country was founded to
do and it sounds odd to say that this
little College in this little corner of
southeastern Michigan can lead a renewal
but it can one thing that has made me
the most excited about learning I think
is looking at history and seeing the
ideas that have shaped our own country
and that is what our purpose is here to
become men and women of character who
make a difference in this country we're
making dallisa was less than the courts
day let's let's let's create a more just
society
well what guides do we have oh I get it
let's go back to the Constitution let's
share these basic texts the threads that
run through these books will run through
my own life and beyond what I'm not here
anymore
there's something of value that
continues on I think that's what's so
beautiful about it
Hillsdale is producing a generation of
missionaries for liberty and that's a
very good thing for a world that's been
long starred for that we do it to
produce a small leavening minority that
will radiate through the whole Republic
we can take that greco-roman and ujo
Christian heritage and see how America
was founded upon those ideals and then
we are stewards of that education today
and so as we leave Hillsdale we take
with us these ideas and we rise to
self-government through education
the college has ever been faithful to
its founding principles which are sound
learner knowing the beautiful and the
good and the true things in support of
civil and religious freedom and
intelligent piety that's what the
college is for it's still for them
you
you